democrats posit that every single bad
thing on planet earth will stop if
donald trump exits the white house
good news on kovid gets buried and chris
pratt finds himself on the wrong side of
the thought police i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let others track what you do keep
yourself safe at expressvpn.com
well we have a lot to get to today we'll
get to all of it in just one second
first
you're spending way too much money on
your mobile phone bill you just are on
your cell phone
bill you're spending tons of money and
there is no reason for that if you're
selling your plan is with verizon at t
t-mobile you're just paying way too much
for the exact same coverage you would be
getting right now
with pure talk take a look at that cell
phone bill where it shows data usage the
average person who switches to pure talk
is using less than four gigs of data a
month but the big carriers are charging
you for unlimited data
it's like paying for an entire row on an
airplane but you only need one seat why
would you do such a thing that's how
pure talk saves the average person over
400 bucks every year
on their wireless service unlimited talk
text and two gigs of data all for just
20 bucks a month
what happens if you go over on data
usage well nothing they don't charge you
for it
folks switching to pure talk is the
easiest decision you will make today
grab your mobile phone
dial pound 250 and say ben shapiro when
you do you say fifty percent off your
first month style pound two five zero
say keyword
ben shapiro pure talk is gonna save you
a lot of money and there's no reason for
you to be spending that money with the
other big cell phone providers instead
go check them out right now style pound
two five zero say keyword ben shapiro
dial pound 250 say keyword
ben shapiro to get started pure talk
simply smarter
wireless okay well over the course of
yesterday
it occurred to me as i was watching the
news flash before my eyes
that we have entered the converse of
what we had during the obama years
during the obama years many in the media
many on the democratic side of the aisle
declared that
that basically barack obama was a
god-like figure there was worship
of barack obama across the land the the
entire comedic infrastructure decided
that jokes could no longer be told we
were told that barack obama was not
funny in any way which of course
is asinine barack obama was hilarious
because the man had such pretensions to
being
a messianic prophet and he fell short of
those pretensions that is inherently
hilarious but you can never make fun of
barack obama instead all of the humor
was directed at barack obama's enemies
because you cannot
cannot tell jokes about god and and that
is the way that it works
on the cultish left with regard to
barack obama he just wasn't funny
he was like our father is what chris
rock said barack obama was this father
figure
to so many folks on the democratic side
of the aisle this cult of personality
was built up around obama not just by
democrats but by members of the media
who declared it off limits to ask him
tough questions or if you yelled a
question
at him then you were considered a racist
i mean the man was given the nobel peace
prize for the great
the the great accomplishment of being an
alive human who was breathing and had
the
correct ethnic heritage right that is
literally why he was given the nobel
peace prize
so it is no wonder that there is another
side
to this gnostic view of the universe in
so many democratic circles
so if barack obama is a sort of god-like
figure then this means that donald trump
is the devil
right donald trump came in he supplanted
barack obama he isn't a fallen angel in
the
mold of lucifer no he is a malevolent
force in the universe
narcissism posits that all of the
universe is torn between these two
forces one is light
and one is dark and when it comes to
politics this is the same idea
promulgated by our media so donald trump
is not just bad donald trump isn't just
a boar he's not just a vulgarian he's
not just a man who says very bad things
he's not just a man who does dumb stuff
or stuff that you disagree with donald
trump is a satanic
dark malevolent figure and all evil in
the universe
revolves around donald trump and this is
the image that has been built up about
trump
and you can sense it you really can when
you talk to democrats
the very idea that anyone would vote for
trump is akin to walking into a catholic
church and saying i'm voting for satan
it is it is akin to walking into any
religious
institution in america and declaring
that you are on the side of the devil
that that is how people view you if you
say that you are going to vote for trump
and you can see it and how people are
treating this i mean first of all there
are the
wild pagans out there who actually are
engaging in pagan ritual
because they hate trump so much there
was a video that was flying around the
internet
over the course of the past week in
which anti-trump protesters literally
set an american flag on fire and then
ate a bloody heart
well meanwhile shouting about indiana
jones or something here was a little bit
of that
that is a dude shouting kalima from
indiana jones
while tearing apart a bloody heart all
over his face while people cheer
on top of a burning american flag i'm on
fire
yeah good times happening over there in
pagan land
but that is just the uh that is just the
visceral
visceral part of the democratic base i
don't think that represents every
democrat by any stretch of the
imagination but the softer version of
that
is that when donald trump leaves office
everything that's bad in the universe is
attributable to trump and when trump
leaves office
we will have purged ourselves as a
country of this great evil
there are only two problems that one not
gonna happen two it means that you now
see the people who live next to you the
people who are voting for donald trump
the people who say that they don't like
joe biden very much or that they are
uncomfortable with both candidates but
they're pulling the lever
for the guy who brought about the
greatest economy in 50 years
you see those people as servants of this
dark malevolent force
you can see that and how folks are
talking again about not only trump but
the people who support trump
if you want to divide the country it's
really not about the election it's about
how you see your neighbors
if you want to destroy the social fabric
it's really not about how you
view the political candidate on the
other side or the political party on the
other side it's how you view the people
who vote for that political party
or that candidate we've been treated to
four long years
of people essentially saying that if you
consider voting republican
when donald trump is president of the
united states or on the ballot this
means that you are
evil in and of yourself okay that is not
something that's going to be bridged if
joe biden is elected it's not like you
come back together
right this is why robert reich the
former treasury secretary under bill
clinton suggested we need a truth and
reconciliation commission
in which anyone in any position of
prominence who supported trump in any
way
is called out and thrown from the public
discourse
the cult of trump hatred has grown
extraordinarily strong
so there's there are gradations here
right the first you get the crazy people
who are ripping apart
i assume pig hearts on public streets
then you get keith olbermann who's only
slightly less crazy keith
olbermann very serious commentator you
can tell he's serious
because he went to cornell agricultural
school and let me
tell you that donald trump is the worst
the most malevolent
the most evil the cruelest the most
disgusting human being
who has ever or will ever walk the earth
keith olbermann
go i'm tired of the thought
that we are now going to repeat the
months of march and april in this
country
a country that should have learned
something but which in large part has
been
authorized to wallow and die in its own
stupidity because of one man
one dumb bastard one selfish son of a
one real life major french attacking the
only hope we have
the science and insisting science is
wrong and fouchy is an idiot and only i
can save you and insisting you can do
whatever you want then the disease
affects almost nobody
donald trump should be on trial for 220
000 murders death penalty for each count
death penalty two so you're going to i
assume according to keith oldman
you're going to juice the man you're
going to you're going to
electrocute donald trump then you're
going to revive him then you'll
electrocute and you'll do this like 220
000 times which is really exciting stuff
from people keith olbermann okay well i
understand
those of you who are moderate left you
know people who are voting for biden
and don't necessarily think like keith
olbermann you're saying yourself right
now shapiro's doing nut-picking right
nut-picking
is this process that people do online or
in politics where you find the most
outlandish versions of what your
opponent is saying and then you
highlight those
but let me explain there is not all that
much difference
in the in the theme here between the
stuff that
crazy pig heart guy and keith olbermann
are saying
and mainstream democrats are saying
elizabeth warren came out over the last
48 hours and suggested that if donald
trump is re-elected
all life on earth will be endangered not
just human life
not just like during his term all life
on the planet
plant life animal life that badger you
love so much
all of them will be endangered by donald
trump's presence
in the oval office this is something
elizabeth warren right the intellectual
of the left
remember she's the lady with the plan
she's the lady with the sweaters and the
plan
she is the person saying that literally
all life he's like an asteroid donald
trump he's going to come at the earth
and
the dinosaurs are dying here is
elizabeth warren
declaring exactly the same thing as pig
heart guy
he not only hasn't made things better he
has actively
made them worse he withdraws from the cl
the paris climate accord
he's put a coal lobbyist in charge of
the environmental protection agency what
could possibly go wrong
he has opened up for offshore drilling
and he has said yes to the oil companies
they can drill
in the arctic national wildlife preserve
donald trump threatens the existence
of human life of all life on this planet
all life on this planet is threatened by
donald trump unless you think it's just
the crazy senator from massachusetts
it's barack obama i mean barack obama
tweeted out in the middle of the
california wildfires
that your life literally depends on
donald trump not being in office
he tweeted out pictures of the wildfires
and and the the bad air quality in san
francisco which by the way again last i
checked
california is a democratic state and
it's wildfire management that is largely
responsible for the wildfires in
california we talked about this at
length
global warming may be responsible for a
slight uptick
in wildfires over the course of the
century but it is not responsible for
the kind of wildfires we saw in
california this year that is solely due
to forest management
but barack obama tweeted out quote the
fires across the west coast are just the
latest examples of the very real ways
our changing climate is changing our
communities
protecting our planet is on the ballot
and then he concluded vote like your
life depends on it
because it does your life depends on how
you vote
right you will die you will be condemned
and consigned to hell on earth if donald
trump is elected president michelle
obama said the exact same thing
and she gave a speech where she said
that you have to vote like your life
depends on it
because it does your life literally
depends on donald trump
not being president of the united states
which is patently crazy
i'm sorry that's nuts there was no point
at which i believed that if barack obama
was re-elected in 2012
life on planet earth was in existential
danger
or i was going to die or family members
were going to die because barack obama
was president of the united states
you have to believe that politics is
religion and religion
has set up this gnostic binary between
absolute good and absolute evil
that is the only way you can come to
this conclusion this is a cult-like
behavior
there's barack obama promoting the cult
of anti-trump
about what would possibly compel you to
accept
this level of chaos violence and
confusion
under this president and be willing to
watch our country continue to spiral out
of control
because we can no longer pretend that we
don't know exactly who
and what this president stands for
search your hearts and then vote for
joe biden like your lives depend on it
vote for joe biden like your lives
depend on it your life depends on it
okay and again that entire commercial if
you can see the imagery it's all white
supremacist marching
and it's it's proud boys firing tear gas
at people and
that again it is absolute good versus
absolute evil that is the binary that is
being drawn this is not a political
difference anymore it is a moral
difference
right this is the binary that democrats
are hoping to draw
and it is cult-like and not only is it
called like people who are leading the
charge here
know that it's cult-like because here's
the deal about being in a cult as you
know from every
documentary you've ever seen the people
in charge of the priesthood of the cult
they're always the ones who benefit if
you are the person who declares that you
are the vessel of all good and your
opponents are the vessel of all evil and
the only way
that your that your constituents can be
purged of that evil
is to embrace the light well cult
leaders usually take advantage of that
right they build people of their money
they they create
you know bizarre sexual rituals cult
leaders get away with nearly anything
and it's they know what they're doing or
if you lead a cult you know what you are
doing
okay pablo gala sort of let the cat out
of the bag today pablo gala the
the democratic commentator you know he
pointed out that for democrats
basically their reaction to this
election is just primal
panic they're stuck somewhere between
excitement and absolute primal panic
because again
they believe that they are right on the
verge of the country falling into
complete disrepair and america
falling into mass chaos and death they
believe they're on the verge of that
and he says and that's exactly where
democrats want them democrats want them
there because it gets them excited about
voting for the democrats
right they channel all of that toward
their own political gain
like that is the goal here when you set
up absolute binaries the person in
charge of the binary is the person who
is
usually set up to gain and that is
exactly what democrats know it is what
democrats are doing
here's paul bagala in fact i talk to
democrats all the time
the most common thing that democrats say
is
they're scared to death and they're
highly motivated and i want them to be
that way
i'm sorry to scream in your ear but
that's that's what they say seriously
you call them
that's what they say a primal scream at
the prospect that somehow trump might
get a second term so they're highly
motivated
in a second we'll get to the predictable
results of all of this
again the complete polarization of the
american public democrats like to
suggest that this is all trump's fault
trump is a reactionary no question but
he is reacting to a thing and the thing
pre-existed trump we'll get to that in
just one second first
let's talk about the fact that not too
long ago if you wanted straighter teeth
you had to have braces
you had to look like you were 13 years
old and you were back in middle school
well not anymore you are a grown adult
and as a grown adult you'd like to
straighten out those teeth but you don't
actually want your mouth filled with
metal
instead what you would love are candid
clear aligners they are comfortable
removable practically invisible unlike
wire braces
you can transform your smile without
anyone noticing plus your treatment is
prescribed and monitored remotely by a
licensed orthodontist who's an expert in
tooth movement
it's all done from the comfort and
convenience of your own home cans it
only works with orthodontist never
general dentists like other companies
plus
your supervising orthodontist will be
with you every single step of the way
with candid your treatment includes
remote monitoring by the same
orthodontist who created your plan
so you never have to wonder how you're
doing you'll always know which i love
okay the average candid treatment is
just six months you'll start seeing
results way before then it costs
thousands less than braces
start straightening your teeth today
right now all my listeners can save 75
bucks on candids
starter kit all you have to do is go to
candidco.com
shapiro and use code shapiro that's
shapiro candidco.com code shapiro take
advantage of this limited time offer to
save 75 bucks
on your starter kit candidco.com shapiro
use code shapiro okay so again this
binary is being drawn by people
who are set to gain from the binary the
absolute division between good and evil
the non-nuanced version of politics and
the castigation of all your political
opponents as servants of satan
this serves a purpose which is why the
lincoln project stewart stephens rick
wilson steve schmidt and reid galen who
have picked up
50 million bucks from the gullible
cult members of the democratic party
they
put 12 million of that toward operating
expenses these guys are buying private
jets
off the cult they have a piece in the
washington post of course of course the
washington post gives them the space
called republicans it's time to choose
between autocracy
and a republic weird because the
democrats right now are threatening to
pack the court
overthrow the filibuster add states
willy-nilly and
strengthen the executive branch that the
legislature becomes a vestigial organ of
american government
but apparently trump is the
authoritarian the lincoln project
suggests that this is an absolute moral
battle an absolute moral battle
and if you come in on the wrong side
then we know that you are damned to hell
they i mean listen to this i see none of
us can choose history
history chooses us if you ever wondered
what side of the edmund pettus bridge
you would have stood on
this is your chance to choose don't you
see donald trump is bill connor the
republicans
people like susan collins in maine and
joni ernst in iowa
these are all bull conors all you have
to do is vote democrat
and you will exercise the demons of the
united states now weirdly enough
americans bought into this garbage in
2008 when great lightbringer obama came
about and it turns out none of the
demons were exercised it turns out that
when you lead a cult
when you have substituted politics for
religion then you can never allow the
grift to end
at that point you can't just say oh well
you know the light has been brought
guess we're done here
it has to be no no no no the devil still
lurks in in
concerted corners the devil still lurks
just in the shadows and so if you give
me more power
if you give me more money if you give me
more ability to control your life
then we'll certainly hunt out the devil
we're always just this far away from
hunting out the devil
but the lincoln project grifters they're
treating this as
not just a political battle that is
important and has ramifications for the
future of the country
but as an absolute moral conflict they
say those who went before face dogs and
fire hoses and yet they did not flinch
in war and peace americans have
displayed unparalleled courage in the
face of evil and injustice
it doesn't take courage to stand up to
trump it takes courage to stand up for
your country
this is the legacy we inherited and are
called to defend this is the choice
america or trump
now is the time to stand with the
country you love
okay i'm sorry that's insane that's
crazy
and and the natural corollary of this is
that people
who disagree with you are not human
beings they're not americans people who
disagree with you are absolute members
of evil
they're they are brown shirts and brown
shirts deserve to be punched
and naturally you see this corollary so
some of the lincoln project grifters
decided they were not happy with the
video that i cut
a few days ago explaining why i'm voting
for trump i explained it in great great
detail without whitewashing i think
any of trump's personality issues i was
heavily critical of the president in
that video where i endorsed
him in 2020 and matthew dowd who i
believe is a member of the lincoln
project
tweeted out ben shapiro isn't a
conservative which
[Laughter]
joe lockhart at cnn then promptly
tweeted out
he's not human he's not human
okay and we all know this okay if you
have ever thought
about not going along with the wilt
crowd if you ever thought about being
friends with a republican if you have
ever thought
about voting for donald trump this is
how members of
the left and i'm talking many mainstream
members of the political left consider
you
you are not human i was human up until
the moment apparently when i
said that trump deserves your vote over
joe biden and a democratic party that's
lost its mind
the minute i said that not human anymore
it was all strange new respect in 2016
when i said epoxy on both your houses in
2020 i said well you know what now i'm
forced to the binary choice
and uh and people lose their you're not
human you're not human
and this is why you see trump supporters
getting punched it's why you see that if
you post
anything pro-trump on your facebook page
your employer may come after you it's
exacerbating the political division
you want to know how you got trump in
the first place this is how you got
trump in the first place
and whatever happens in the election
it's not going to end
it is not as though democrats are going
to recede into a unity campaign that is
a lie
it is not that the left is going to stop
marching as soon as
donald trump is out of office again the
cult can never
stop hunting the devil that is not the
way this works donald trump can be put
out of office and it's not like
everything goes back to normal tomorrow
it's just that donald trump is no longer
the face of the of the satanic force
that democrats and members of the left
believe exists out there
they'll find a new phase in 2012 they
somehow pasted that face on mitt romney
in 2024 i assume they'll paste that face
on somebody else and in between they
will simply declare that anybody who
disagrees with them
is a member of that of that deathly
squad
of trump supporters and you can see
mainstream democrats have picked up on
this
to even treat a republican as a normal
human being is now worthy of
condemnation
perfect example today chuck schumer the
senate minority leader
he came out and he condemned dianne
feinstein dion feinstein is one of the
left most members of the united states
senate
she was my senator in california for my
entire life essentially i think she was
elected in 1994.
okay very hard left senator but in the
aftermath of the amy coney barrett
hearings
she said that the hearings were civil
and nice and then she hugged lindsey
graham
this was a sin against the cult and
chuck schumer
member of the high caste of the
priesthood of the anti-trump
cult he says that dianne feinstein must
be mansplained to
some progressive groups have spoken out
criticizing senator feinstein for her
handling of the hearings
i was wondering when you make this
criticism and do you plan to make any
changes to the judiciary committee
okay i've had a long and serious talk
with senator feinstein
that's all i'm going to say about it
right now
okay so um he talked to her he talked to
her because
she had the temerity to hug a republican
and treat a republican as a human being
this is not allowed we cannot allow this
this sort of activity we just we just
cannot
now the cult like behavior is most
focused when it comes to treatment of
kobit
because covid is a perfect way for
democrats to pretend
that these vast global forces have a
certain morality to them there's a
paganistic
aspect to the left's treatment of covet
now if you look at covet with any sort
of objective eye what you'll notice
is that covet has devastated countries
around the globe regardless of political
orientation
it devastated new york it devastated new
jersey it devastated massachusetts
you'll note that washington dc got
slammed
you'll also note that there has been a
heavy case load in europe all across
europe heavy case loads france heavy
case load uk heavy caseload both of them
have a higher death per million rate
than the united states
heavy case load in italy right there's
tons right now the eu is outpacing the
united states
in terms of identified coveted 19 cases
but
in the same way that so many democrats
talk about global warming
as a sort of as a sort of natural force
that has descended upon
america thanks to donald trump right
we're all going to die if donald trump
isn't president
unless donald trump is is thrust from
the presidency in the same way
kovid is a moral virus according to many
members of the left
and we were treated to this particular
notion in the in the very beginning of
this thing
when people were not only angry at trump
but they also decided that kova did not
matter so long as you were protesting
for racial justice
at this point it became perfectly clear
that cult-like behavior
was not relegated to non-coveted matters
kovit was now seen
in the same way that the black plague
was seen back when it hit europe
the the the priesthood of the time
suggested that this was sort of god's
revenge for sinful mankind
well this is exactly how many members of
the left view covet
covid is either directly facilitated by
trump trump is the coveted president or
covet has hit us because we sort of
deserve it and it's trump's failures
that have caused all of this never mind
the fact that it's devastated countries
all over the world that nobody has a
great handle on it
and unless you had initial low case load
everybody gets hit by this thing because
it's extraordinarily
transmissible the way the democrats
portray kovid is that every single death
from covet is attributable to donald
trump because donald trump is the
malevolent force the virus of course
is uh wonderfully woke if you were out
protesting about george floyd and you
weren't wearing a mask and you were
twerking in the streets for george floyd
or you were burning down a business for
george floyd you weren't wearing a mask
and you were
and you were giving cove it to other
people and by the way you want to see
the media coverage uh biased media
coverage look at how they they covered
the george floyd protest as compared to
memorial day they happened around the
same time
a spike happened in covet cases
approximately two weeks later
and the case the media made was it was
all memorial day and none of the
millions wide protests
this moral virus came to america because
of donald trump
so the the chief focus of their attack
is this quasi-religious appeal
that if donald trump were to go away
then the plague would recede
right if donald trump would go away the
black plague would suddenly recede all
the buboes would be popped
and everything would be fine this is not
implicit this is explicit democrats have
been arguing this thing explicitly
they ignore all good news to do so they
ignore what the trump administration is
doing they downplay what the trump
administration is doing
in order to come to this conclusion this
is the argument nonetheless we'll get to
that in just one second first
we are just weeks away from election day
early in-person voting has already
started in a huge number of battleground
states arizona michigan georgia ohio
florida
you're turning out in record-setting
numbers and there are many more states
where early in-person voting
has begun or is about to begin well this
is why you need to get organized the
democrats are not going to leave anybody
on the bench at this time
the liberals are going to get out their
voters you need to get out your friends
to vote right now if you haven't visited
keepamericamerica.com i'm urging you to
visit it right now
the voting information and free
resources they provide are trusted and
up to date
while you're there you can even sign up
and be kept up to date via email the
2016 election was decided by thousands
of votes
not millions of votes the nearly 400 000
of you across the country who have gone
to keepamerica america.com that needs to
grow to a million before the election
let's make this the biggest get out the
vote effort in conservative history one
the left-wing media cannot ignore
there are simple but vitally important
things you can do right now vote
visit keepamerica america.com and commit
to take just one other person
to the polls just one or help somebody
complete a mail-in ballot do a little
bit do a lot but do your part go to
keepamericamerica.com right now again
that is keepamericamerica.com
right now okay so again the narrative
from the media
this pagan narrative that donald trump
is responsible for every ill on planet
earth
covet is his fault not china if you said
chinese virus you're a racist but if you
called it the trump virus this was just
good politics and obviously true
joe biden literally said just a few
weeks ago that if donald trump had done
his job
every single human being who died of
coveted in the united states would still
be alive
that's an insane statement it's an it
was trotted forth at the dnc by the way
they literally put out a video of a
woman from arizona who said that because
her father voted for donald trump and
believed donald trump he was dead from
covet that's nuts
the vast majority of people in the
united states who have died from covet i
would bet you money
did not die having voted for donald
trump
because blue states have been hit harder
in terms of death than red states have
okay turns out the fighters doesn't care
about your politics but
democrats members of the media they
certainly care about your politics and
so they're going to use the brick bat of
kovad
to suggest that this nefarious dark
force this measmatic evil that is donald
trump
he goes away everything will get better
here is joe biden suggesting that every
death in america
attributable to covet is actually
attributable to trump if the president
had done his job
had done his job from the beginning all
the people would still be alive
all the people i'm not making this up
just look at the data
look at the data okay every single one
of them look at the data and then they
and then they appeal to science
right so their twin gods are are the
democratic party and science right joe
biden and science except for the fact
that of course they don't believe
in science too much and boys can be
girls and girls can be boys
and babies inside the womb are clusters
of mere cells
and we can alleviate global warming by
building
like high-speed rail or some such
nonsense
that sort of stuff is just that that's
an obvious religious appeal is it not
right vote for me and i will bring those
200 000 people back to life or at least
i will stop all further death gretchen
whitmer made the same point the governor
of michigan
and she suggested that the reason the
only reason you are wearing masks right
now is because donald trump is president
if it were not for trump nobody would be
wearing a mask weird because i'm looking
all over europe and everybody is wearing
a mask and they are going back into
lockdown
in fact countries like sweden that
hero24 had been kind of light on the
lockdowns they're using targeted
lockdowns now
seems as though nobody's in control of
this thing but according to gretchen
whitmer if you had just cast out the
evil force that is donald trump
no one would be wearing a mask we'd all
be back at ball games here is gretchen
whitmer saying an absolutely untrue
thing
220 000 dead we've got people
in food pantry lines who never would
have imagined that they'd be there
and no light on the horizon because our
numbers keep going up
this is a gravely serious moment for all
of us and if you're tired of lockdowns
or you're tired of
wearing masks or you wish you were in
church this morning or watching college
football or your kids were in
person instruction it is time for change
in this country and that's why we've got
to elect joe biden
ah well if you elect joe biden then you
won't have to wear a mask anymore the
sunlight will shine through the clouds
covered will end all of the people who
are in hospitals and in icu's right now
all of them will just get up and they'll
start walking anew joe biden will lay
his hands upon them
maybe he'll get his friend barack obama
to it they'll they'll they'll lay their
messianic hands upon those who are ill
and they will heal the ill
and they will walk again they will walk
again how toxic is donald trump in this
viewpoint he's so toxic that if donald
trump even mentions a vaccine
the vaccine becomes untouchable that's
how evil he is donald trump has even
ruined vaccines
andrew cuomo governor of new york says
that if
a vaccine is approved before the end of
the year he still will not trust it
okay now this is honestly this is not
even political this is just cultish
immorality if a vaccine is approved
before the end of the year post-election
we're already going to know who won the
presidency
in december we're already going to know
who won the presidency at that point
even if you believe that trump
was willing to lie about a vaccine and
that his scientists were also willing to
lie about a vaccine
in the run-up to an election at that
point it's after the election so there's
no further incentive
for there to be any untruth about a
vaccine even if you were even if you
were likely to believe for some odd
reason that scientists were willing to
lie and kill
presumably tens of thousands of human
beings in order to push a false vaccine
on trump's behalf which is a crazy
proposition in the first place
andrew cuomo is now out there
downplaying the development of vaccine
that will only be out after the election
happens
okay that is because donald trump is so
evil that everything he touches turns to
draws
here is andrew cuomo religious leader
i'm not that confident
but my opinion doesn't matter i don't
believe the american people
are that confident you're going to say
to the american people now
here's a vaccine it was new it was done
quickly
but trust this federal administration
and their health
administration that it's safe uh
and um we're not 100 sure of the
consequences
i think it's going to be a very
skeptical american public about taking
the vaccine and they should be
they should be they should be skeptical
about taking the vaccine even after the
election
even when trump isn't going to be the
lead on this thing and then
kevin newsom the governor of california
said the same thing he said he's going
to set up his own board
in california in order to determine if a
vaccine is safe so we're going to wait
for two more months for the california's
bureaucracy to work its way through the
vaccine to determine if it's safe
before anybody in california can take
the vaccine so you've now just extended
gavin newsom's
onerous lockdowns for months on end
based on nothing except for the idea
that trump
is nefarious and evil by the way how bad
are those lockdowns disneyland just
announced they will be shut for the
foreseeable future
despite the fact that they say they know
how to open the labor unions want to
open but gavin newsom has continued to
keep disneyland shut
worth noting disney world here in
florida where i am disney world has been
open since june
they have apparently zero outbreaks at
disney world but
still you can't go to disneyland in
california because gavin newsom says so
because trump is evil here is gavin
newsom
california today is launching now more
formally a scientific
safety review a work group of 11
individuals
experts in their field these are top
health experts that will independently
review
any fda approved vaccines no question
i often get is are you going to take
someone's word
for it as it relates vaccines of course
we don't take anyone's
word for it we will do our own
independently reviewed
process with our world-class experts
the fda is bad now because the devil got
to the fda right donald trump
was in charge of the fda therefore the
fda is corrupt therefore the fda will
put out flawed vaccine in order to harm
americans post-election
when it doesn't matter to trump's
electoral prospects one iota
makes perfect sense the only way to make
sense of this again it is a moral battle
by the way
all of this requires you to completely
ignore actual good things happening on
the ground
we are going to develop a vaccine it
will happen presumably by the end of the
year according to pfizer
not only that two new peer-reviewed
studies according to npr are showing a
sharp drop in mortality among
hospitalized covenant patients
the drop is seen in every group
including older patients and those with
underlying conditions
suggesting that physicians are getting
better at helping patients survive their
illness
the study which was of a single health
system finds that mortality has dropped
among hospitalized patients by 18
percentage points
since the pandemic began that actually
is understating the size of the drop
why because it depends on
proportionality patients in the study
had a 25.6 chance of dying at the start
of the pandemic
they now have a 7.6 chance of dying
okay so that is a reduction from nearly
to nearly 8 so put that another way that
is about a 300 reduction
in death rate in hospitals right or put
a different way it's about a 75 to 80
reduction in death rate in hospitals
that's pretty impressive is it not
it's pretty incredible is it not that's
good news that we should be celebrating
and maybe it should be an impetus for us
to start opening things up again
yes being careful yes socially
distancing yes mask wearing when we
when we can't stay away from other
people but instead it's
everything is wrong everything is bad
we're all going to die unless we get rid
of trump in which case everything will
be good again
not only that i mean we can tell i mean
the data are out there now
that death tolls are up in in
non-vulnerable populations from a wide
variety of other diseases
thanks to lockdown excess deaths for
example
from all causes was up among adults aged
25 to 44
26.5 right that is the the largest
number of excess deaths by percentage
right there are lots of excess deaths in
the
in the elderly age range but excess
deaths generally means people who would
not have died anyway elderly people are
more apt to die from a wide variety of
other causes
excess deaths among young people are
really up extremely dramatically
and a lot of that is deaths of despair
we are seeing
highs in terms of deaths of despair we
are seeing that
in in great britain for example figures
from the office for national statistics
for march to september
reveal that almost a thousand deaths are
being recorded every week
up 26 000 on the same period last year
among the biggest killers are diabetes
of 86
parkinson's 79 prostate cancer 53 breast
cancer 47
and bowel cancer 46 so there's excess
deaths of despair in young people and
then among
people who are older there are a lot of
people who are not going to the hospital
and they should be so what does the data
tell us it tells us that we shouldn't be
locking down
we should instead be cautious and we
should be open and there's good news our
hospitals are getting better at this
instead everything comes down to trump
in the united states we ignore the fact
that this virus is not relegated to the
united states alone
and instead it all becomes about if we
get rid of trump then magically the sun
will shine again perhaps the clearest
example of this
is how democrats are treating schools so
the data are in
schools are not unsafe they are not
unsafe there's a piece in the wall
street journal today
by david henderson and ryan sullivan
tens of millions of students started the
school year completely online including
those in 13 of the 15 largest school
districts in the united states
the primary reason is concern over
safety for students and staff but recent
data are shifting the discussion on
school safety and infection rates of
coven they argue strongly for opening
k-12 schools previous evidence has
suggested schools are not super spreader
that research came from other countries
or very specific cases in america like
ymca
summer camps while this suggested little
impact on infection rates from opening
the schools
it was possible that maybe schools would
be different outcomes in the united
states but they're about the same
a group of researchers spearheaded by
brown university professor emily oster
have created and made available the most
comprehensive database on schools and
coveted case rates for students and
staff
since the pandemic started her data
covering almost 200
000 kids across 47 states from the last
two weeks of september
showed a covet case rate of 0.13 among
students and 0.24
among staff that's a shockingly and
wonderfully low number number by
comparison the overall us case rate is
2.6 percent
in order of magnitude higher other
research has shown hospitalization and
fatality rates for school-age children
are also extremely low people 19 and
younger account for only 1.2 percent of
coven-19 hospitalizations in the united
states
during the peak of the pandemic the cdc
reported that of all covenant 19 deaths
up to october
10th only 74 were children under age 15.
during the 2019-2020 flu season the cds
the cdc estimates that 434
children under 18 died of the flu but we
don't shut down schools
over the flu how about teachers well it
turns out that
various countries that never shut their
schools say teachers have the same
fatality rate
as people in other professions the cost
of reopening
the schools measured in hospitalizations
and fatalities is low
okay it doesn't matter again the pagan
argument goes that so long as trump is
president we cannot open the schools
under any circumstances it's trump's
fault this clothes are closed and
therefore trump goes away
we can talk about reopening the schools
otherwise the schools stay shut
again this is a pagan argument you have
now substituted politics for religion
and if you get rid of this evil
nefarious trump
everything goes back to normal magically
the light shines once more
and we'll get to more of this in just
one second
first i got to talk to you about a
service that is absolutely gonna blow
you away
so right now look on your phone okay on
your phone you have many many pictures
many of them are beautiful and wonderful
you look at them once you show them all
your friends but then you never actually
put them anywhere right you don't print
them out you don't do anything with them
why because it's a hassle it's a pain in
the butt i'm going to give you the
easiest and best and most beautiful way
to display your favorite photos it is
super simple i've done it myself it is
incredible
i'm talking right now about my friends
at my photo right now right now
find your favorite photo on your phone
okay and then email that photo to ben
myphoto.com again that's ben at
myphoto.com you don't need to put in a
subject line even
in seconds after you email it my photo
is going to send you back your photo
already placed on all kinds of products
if you love what you see you can buy
right from the email it's really cool
it's really easy you can see exactly
what you're buying
and it's free to try so give it a shot
okay i have a couple of acrylic photos
from myphoto.com they are beautiful i
mean they just look spectacular so much
better than just printing out a photo
and putting it in a frame it's a giant
painting in the butt to do that
instead email your favorite photo right
now use your phone
email your favorite photos you've been
at myphoto.com you can see all the
various options
these are photo products handmade of
metal wood glass and more you'll want
one for yourself
you'll want to order one for your family
members as a gift it's never too early
to shop for the holiday season in fact
get it out of the way
right now by the way i know the founders
of myphoto.com they are fantastic
fantastic honorable honest folks i know
them really well
and their their service is an amazing
service do it right now it's crazy easy
it's crazy fast
email it to ben myphoto.com you'll be
able to get 25
off your order just because you did that
just because of mwah once again email
that photo right now to ben
myphoto.com in seconds my photo will
send you back that amazing email for you
to see
your picture on all of their products
and from that email if you like what you
see can buy any of their great
photo products and again you get 25 off
your order when you use that then at
myphoto.com just go there pick your
favorite pick
email it right now it's free to see
there's an obligation email that photo
today to ben my photo dot com okay
we're gonna get in a second to the
cultic refusal to open up the schools
until post election we'll get to that in
just one second first
you may have noticed this has been a
completely insane year statues toppled
coupled with radical rioting looting in
american cities it can feel at times
like america is coming apart well right
now would be the perfect time to read my
book how to destroy america in three
easy steps the book is really
a primer on america it's not just about
destroying america in three easy steps
and how disintegration is wish to do it
it really is about why america is worth
holding together it's about the
philosophy
culture and history of the united states
you want to give your kid an education
in what's great about the united states
that's what this book is about and it
discusses why people are trying to tear
it down and how they are trying to tear
it down
why they are looking at the philosophy
of the united states the philosophy
of the declaration and trying to throw
it out why they are looking at the
culture of entrepreneurialism and
adventure and tolerance of the united
states and they're trying to destroy it
why they are trying to
pretend that the history of the united
states is an unmitigated
role of evil as opposed to what it
really is an incredible
story of good triumphing over evil and
over the evils of human nature
progressively over time check out my
book how to destroy america in three
easy steps it is not just relevant for
the election is relevant long past the
election
it is the best inoculation against
leftist claptrap i think
if not ever written then certainly on
the market today go check it out right
now how to destroy america in three easy
steps
now meanwhile as with everything in 2020
there's been a lot of drama with the
presidential debates but
we are ready for the second and final
debate this thursday join us at 8 45 pm
eastern
5 45 pm pacific for an all-new episode
of daily wire backstage you can watch
the debate with us you can get our
immediate live reaction to this major
political event even better
join daily wear right now as an insider
or all access member get 20
off with code debate so you can watch
all the debate coverage live on our
apple tv or roku app members get our
articles ad free
access to all of our live broadcasts and
show library the full three hours of the
ben shapiro show exclusive readers past
content
available only to dailywire members if
you're considering an all-access
membership you get to join us on all
access live every night for online and
live stream discussions
you also get not one but to you leftist
years tumblers with your membership as
well as early sometimes exclusive access
to new daily wire products so become a
member today watch the debate with us
over at dailywire.com youtube and
facebook get 20 off your daily wire
membership with code
debate when you sign up today you are
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
again so the argument that democrats
keep making is that they cannot open the
schools until after
the election if you look at washington
dc they've openly announced that they
are preparing to welcome up to 21 000
elementary school students back for
in-person learning in november
why not right now well november you know
like november is a better time
probably after the election that'd be
like a real good time to do it according
to the
washington dc ist the dc is
this on october 5th so if it's good
enough to open like in november why
isn't it good enough to open
right now you're losing a full month of
education it is hitting people who are
low income at the hardest
i mean really zoom education sucks okay
i know my kids have been doing it
basically it is homeschooling you may as
well homeschool
teachers very often can't see the
students very often
students just log in and then walk away
from the computer many people aren't
even logging in the truancy rates are
incredible and yet we are told that
months on end
another month of this won't hurt
anything it's totally fine you know
another month of this is fine just get
past the election
why well said chancellor lewis farabee
learning at home has been positive for
many of our students because of the
extraordinary work of our teachers
we also know at this time that learning
at home is not working for every student
under the first option considered by the
washington dc school districts about 7
000 students will attend in-person
classes led by a teacher each school
will offer one class for each grade
beginning on
november 9th oh look at that right after
the election
what a coincidence who could have
predicted
him meanwhile in l.a county barbara
farrar
the l.a county department of health
public official whose
degree is not in anything related to
public health barbara ferrara she says
you know um why don't we reevaluate this
whole school's being closed thing you
know like after the election that feels
like a good time
so we uh don't realistically anticipate
that we would be moving either tier two
or
to reopening uh k-12 schools at least
through
uh at least until after the election
after
you know in early november like when we
just look at the timing of everything
it seems to us a more realistic approach
to this would be to think that we're
going to be where we are
now until uh we get after
until we we are done with the elections
oh well you know after the election is
when you're gonna
now what is the logic behind this again
the logic is that trump
is causing it trump is causing the
lockdowns even though he opposes
lockdowns
trump is causing the schools to be
closed even though he wants the schools
open
they're not going to follow the science
not on vaccines not on schooling trump
the evil trump he's out there prowling
prowling in the shadows wearing a jason
mask
he's coming after you you never know
trump might be in your house
right now you just never know i mean joe
biden has said this openly he said if it
weren't for trump schools would be open
right now
well if you listen to trump's schools
we'll be open right now you douche here
is john
here is joe biden but this year we're
facing the most difficult circumstances
and we're seeing an awful lot of heart
and a lot of grit
from our educators our students and to
try to rise to the occasion here
well our government hasn't come up to
that bar i haven't shown much grit at
all or determination
let me be clear if president trump
and his administration had done their
jobs early on
with this crisis america's schools would
be open
and to be open safely instead american
families
all across this country are paying the
price for his failures
it is joe biden who's been saying that
if the science tells me it's all locked
down
right joe biden at the dnc did the same
thing she had a whole speech from an
elementary school classroom that was
empty
in which she's like the quiet it's it's
such a heavy quiet
and then she made the overt religious
appeal right she it's quiet because of
donald trump
but joe joe will make us hold let me
tell you something
if you believe this crap you're a sucker
okay you're a sucker to believe it about
obama
if you're on the right and you believe
that trump is a cult leader you're a
sucker anybody who believes a political
leader
ought to be trusted with this kind of
power or believes that this person will
be the solution
to all your problems you're a sucker and
politicians know that you are a sucker
but there's a sucker born every single
minute at least you could be forgiven
for thinking of barack obama who's at
least very well styled rhetorically
and spoke in these lofty terms at least
you could be forgiven for treating him
as some sort of quasi-messianic figure i
guess from from a political
observational standpoint
treating joe biden as a messianic figure
are you out of your damn mind
he's a geriatrical corrupt senator i
mean like what what are we even talking
about
it's boss tweed messiah boss tweet over
here
uh-huh okay here is joe biden saying
that th the silence is heavy but joe
will remove the silence
again the light will begin to shine in
in hebrew bosco
the the the voice of god will emerge
from the clouds
it'll be like sinai and it'll come down
going come on man
here is joe biden this quiet
is heavy you can hear the anxiety that
echoes down
empty hallways there's no scent of new
notebooks or freshly waxed floors
i know that if we entrust
this nation to joe he will do for your
family
what he did for ours bring us
together and make us whole meanwhile if
you doubt any of the prevailing
coveted narrative that is being put out
by the media or by the democrats
then this means that you are engaging in
ultra crepitarianism
right which is a big word that just
means operating outside your your sphere
of knowledge
right so jake tapper and sanjay gupta
sanjay gupta by the way neuroscientist
who uh misread chris cuomo's lung charts
on air on cnn
he accuses scott atlas of engaging
outside of his field of expertise
ignoring the fact that there are a lot
of people who disagree with anthony
fauci about particular policies
including
including jay bhattacharya from stanford
who actually is an epidemiologist there
are lots of epidemiologists out there
that don't all agree with anthony fauci
on everything there is to say
but again the idea is that we have set
up this coterie this this beautiful
priesthood of the knowledgeable and the
knowledgeable are democrats and people
who trump doesn't like like anthony
fauci here was
sanjay gupta and jake tapper accusing
scott atlas who is one of the white
house advisors
of engaging in ultra crepitarianism well
meanwhile engaging in ultra
crepitarianism because neither sanjay
gupta nor jake tap our epidemiologist
scott atlas is a neuroradiologist he is
not
an expert on infectious diseases and
this is what president trump likes to do
he likes to get these people
like oral surgeons who are not experts
on infectious disease
attest to either how great he is
or how the pandemic should be treated
how
the federal response should be dr scott
ellis might be a very smart guy
but what he is doing right now is
reinforcing these beliefs he tweets out
masks no that tweet has to be taken down
okay so again
it is fun to watch as uh as we say that
scott atlas knows nothing
but sanchez gupta knows everything which
is an interesting take
now here is the beauty of living in this
world if donald trump is the devil
then that's the only way that you can
get joe biden to be what you need him to
be if you want people to be enthusiastic
about voting for him
if you want people enthused about voting
for joe biden you somehow have to have
to transform
this near 80 year old near octogenarian
non-coherent
finger in the wind corrupt politician
career-long corrupt politician who
has sponged off the public dime since he
was 30 years old
you have to treat that guy as a sort of
lightbringer a bringing together dude
right and that's that's a hard task so
the worse trump is the better biden is
by contrast so while joe biden declares
that the people who don't support him
are not black if they if they are black
and support trump they're not actually
black
well joe biden declares that if you
support trump then you're
probably a racist well joe biden
declares and has his surrogates declare
that all human life on earth is put in
danger
by donald trump's presidency which means
that if you support him
you are by nature by by simple logic you
are now supporting the end of all human
life
on earth and animal life and plant life
according to elizabeth warren
that guy is now portraying himself as
captain unity because again if you give
him power everything not only goes back
to normal it's better than it ever was
the lion lies with the lamb all of your
swords are beat into plowshares
jeffrey tubin stops beating other things
right everything just messianically
fixes itself and that is this new joe
biden ad narrated by sam elliott
it's an ad that any republican could
have cut okay but here is joe biden's
closing pitch which is
i am america
there is only one america
no democratic rivers no republican
mountains
just this great land and all that's
possible on it
with a fresh start
cures we can find futures
we can shape work to reward
dignity to protect there is so much
we can do if we choose to take on
problems
and not each other and choose
a president who brings out our best
joe biden doesn't need everyone in this
country to
always agree just to agree
we all love this country
and go from there i'm joe biden
and i approve this message so that's the
pitch
the pitch is lightbringer joe versus
devil dawn right
that is the pitch that the democrats are
making if they have to twist facts in
order to get there they will
if they have to lie to you in order to
get there they will and if they have to
treat everybody who they dislike as an
untouchable
they will which brings us to the way
that media and social media and
hollywood
are treating all of this and the
whitewashing of joe biden
okay so let's start with hollywood okay
yesterday
chris pratt began to trend the actor the
guy from guardians of the galaxy
and you remember he originally got his
start in parks and recreation he's
really funny he's a talented actor he
also happens to be a religious christian
and well chris pratt is not an overt joe
biden supporter he's not said who he's
supporting in the election
this is verboten you're not allowed to
do this chris pratt there was a there's
a little
unofficial poll online okay what it was
is just somebody tweeted out
which is the worst chris and it was like
chris pine and uh and chris evans
and chris hemsworth by the way if you
are going to rank the chris in terms of
acting talent
it obviously goes pine hemsworth
pratt evans maybe pine pratt hemsworth
evans evans is clearly the worst and
though the worst christ is clearly evans
i mean there's no doubt about this he's
the most bland
terrible act i mean chris evans is just
not a good actor okay but put aside my
own antipathy for
captain america who once said that he
really dislikes me i don't dislike him i
mean he seems like
a fairly nice guy except for the fact
that he uh he castigates his political
opposition as evil all the time aside
from that he seems like a fairly
decent fellow but in any case this
little poll goes around online
which is the worst chris who is the
worst chris chris pratt
is the is the clear trend why why is he
the worst chris
well he is the worst chris because he is
not siding with joe biden
he's a bad man because he he didn't do
an avengers table read
for biden so the avengers stars reunited
for a joe biden fundraiser because this
is the way it works in hollywood
in the last few days we've had a happy
days reunion for biden in wisconsin
with ron howard and henry winkler we had
a seinfeld reunion for biden
in texas with larry david julia louise
dreifus and uh
and jason alexander and we had an
avengers movie for biden
right so hollywood it turns out supports
joe biden
so contrary to popular perception demi
lovato cutting an anti-trump
music video is not actually going to put
her career in danger remember she said
when she cut her her dumb music video
commander-in-chief
she would she'll do this even if it puts
her career in danger
okay so chris pratt was dragged on
twitter for the great sin
of not having attended this avengers
table read
and his co-stars came out and like
decent human beings they were like uh
actually chris pratt's a nice guy so
mark ruffalo who is a rabid democrat
right he tweeted out you all chris pratt
is as solid a man as there is
i know him personally instead of casting
aspersions look at how he lives his life
he is just not overtly political as a
rule
this is a distraction let's keep our
eyes on the prize friends we are so
close now robert downey jr also shared
an image of himself and chris pratt
said what a world the sinless are
casting stones and my brother chris
pratt a real christian who lives by
principle has never demonstrated
anything but positivity and gratitude
and he just married into a family that
makes space for civil discourse and just
plain facts insists on
on service has the highest value if you
take issue with chris i've got a novel
idea delete your social media accounts
sit with your own defensive character
work on them and then celebrate your
humanness
chris pratt i got your back okay and
james gunn also came out in support of
chris pratt
now here's the thing do you think any of
those actors would come out in support
of someone they didn't personally know
this is the way it works in leftist
hollywood and leftist hollywood if you
personally know
an open conservative like jon voight or
adam baldwin then they are acceptable
and decent people if not they are bad
people and you should never hire them
so chris pratt getting dragged for the
simple sin of not supporting biden he
doesn't even support trump
he's never said a word about supporting
trump he gets dragged anyway because
when you set up the binary
between you support biden as a as a cure
to all of the problems and ills of the
world
or you are a bad person that binary
holds
it also means that there is now an
excuse for media and social media
to cover for every bit of bad behavior
and this is why you saw a former twitter
executive yesterday saying that social
media platforms should mute president
trump
i mean why not after all trump is satan
you have to mute trump you can't let him
get his message out
because better that you should misuse
your
chair at the head of america's social
media companies
to prevent dissemination of information
than to let a bad evil bad very bad
orange bad no bad terrible bad man like
donald trump
tweet things i mean the hilarious thing
about this is that trump's tweets if he
loses the election will probably have
been a key reason why but
the social media heads don't want
anything trump says to penetrate here is
a former twitter executive saying social
media platforms should mute trump
in the lead-up to the election according
to a recent harvard study
the leading uh generators of
false information come from the top it's
coming from donald trump
and some of the leading conservative
voices that echo him we are in a unique
and i believe a fraught moment in time
with a
president who is desperate and he's
facing a very difficult situation
i think the time is to mute the
president temporarily while the
votes are being cast right now and until
the winner is decided
social media has decided that because
trump is the devil it's time to violate
every rule
that social media was supposed to be
about remember social media was supposed
to be about the open discussion and
dissemination of ideas
so now what is twitter doing so twitter
decided
in the run-up to the election you are no
longer allowed to just retweet things
why aren't you allowed to just retweet
things because what they are afraid of
is that you are going to retweet a link
from the new york post
or you will retweet a trump tweet
without comment and that it will rock it
around the internet
and they're hoping that they will slow
the reality of inf informational
movement by forcing you to type in a
couple of words
that's not going to work people will
figure out workarounds but they are
making this perfectly obvious
right they've made this obvious they
said that it's about the election they
said that you're no longer just allowed
to retweet things because then you might
retweet what trump is saying
and it might rocket around the internet
you might retweet that new york post
story and people might find out about it
so now instead
you have to put your own spin or
commentary on it in order to even tweet
it out
not only that they are now quote unquote
showing context on trends in explore
is according to twitter quote to make
high quality information around the 2020
us elections more accessible
we're adding context to trends and only
displaying trends with added context
in the for you tab oh how interesting
so now trends are going to be
contextualized by twitter so twitter
will explain to you how things work
isn't that extraordinary now twitter
you're too stupid you understand so
twitter is going to have to explain to
you
why things are trending and they will
explain it to you i'm sure in the least
biased possible way i'm sure that's
exactly what's going to happen
meanwhile we are supposed to completely
ignore any serious questions about joe
biden
so day after day there are more kind of
drips and traps
about about joe biden and hunter biden
so apparently there is a new twist in
the hunter biden saga
this is andrew mccarthy who is revealing
it
he says it turns out that hunter biden
brought an elite chinese group to the
white house to meet with joe biden
quote just imagine if something like
this happened during the trump
administration ask yourself what the
media democrat complex would be saying
in november 2011 an elite group
of chinese communist party members and
billionaire cronies of the repressive
regime in beijing
secured a meeting in the white house
said to be with vice president biden and
other obama administration officials
through hunter biden's associates oh
look at that
news of the meeting has been broken by
peter schweitzer and seamus bruner
schweitzer who has spent years tracking
washington's web of money influence and
access
is the author most recently of secret
empires which focuses on the biden
family among other intriguing money
trails on both sides of the political
aisle
schweitzer and bruner have obtained the
cooperation of hunter biden's former
business partner bevan cooney who is
serving a federal prison sentence for a
fraud scheme
another hunter biden business partner
devin archer was also convicted
hunter biden was featured in the
evidence but not charged cooney has
given the investigative journalist
access to his email account which
contains
years of correspondence with biden
archer and others the authors have begun
writing reports published at breitbart
schweitzer
has also been interviewed about this on
hannity obviously these are very
pro-trump venues it is worth noting that
solid reporting schweitzer did on the
clinton foundation was closely examined
and relied upon by the new york times
based on cooney's emails the authors
report that in november 2011
hunter biden's business associates
arranged meetings at the obama white
house for a delegation of the
china entrepreneur club established in
2006 the cec is led by high officials of
the chinese communist party
some government officials including
diplomats and billionaire business
executives with close ties to the regime
this visit to the white house is said to
have included a meeting with then vice
president biden
in discussions amongst themselves hunter
biden's associates reportedly made it
clear
they anticipated cashing in on business
prospects that were expected to arise
from providing the chinese
with with high level access to the obama
administration
according to the schweitzer bruner
report the cec had struck out
trying to get meetings with top obama
officials until they contacted hunter
biden's associates
through an intermediary named muhammad
khashoggi
on an october 19 2011 email in which he
described
the cec visitors as china inc khashoggi
told hunter's associate gary freers that
helping the group could be a good
opportunity for paddy to have
potentially
outstanding new clients it is not clear
to whom patty refers
khashoggi elaborated he understood
people are hesitant but he said a group
like this does not come along every day
the cec contingent was hoping for a tour
of the white house and a meeting with a
member of the chief of staff's office as
well as
john kerry who of course was at the time
chairing the foreign relations committee
in the senate and later became the
secretary of state
devon archer is of course his his
stepson
i believe khashoggi stressed it to fear
that the cec's mandate was to let the
united states know that the the
chinese private sector is ready and
willing to invest in america
so they ended up setting up the meeting
apparently on november 11th archer sent
freers
two emails in quick succession because
he wanted to leave hunter out of the
second one in the first
on which hunter and bevan cooney were
copied archer said
that he had met with khashoggi he had
gone well and it seemed like there's a
lot to do together down the line
although khashoggi did not appear to be
a fit for the current potash
private placement archer anticipated his
he's a good strategic relationship
as the mind develops archer encouraged
fears and cooney to meet with khashoggi
in miami he also explained hunter had
not been able to call fears because
hunter is traveling in the uae with
royalty
one minute later archer sent a one-line
email to fears and kumiti
kuni omitting hunter in which he said
couldn't confirm this with hundred
online but we got him presumably
khashoggi his meeting at the white house
monday
for the chinese folks the white house
meeting did occur monday november 14th
in an email cooney informed fears that
archer got all the chinese guys taken
care of in dc
the chinese visitors got high-level
access including a personal meeting with
vice president biden according to the
authors it was an off the books meeting
not recorded in the official white house
logs so this is all a story that is
completely independent
of the emails developed by the new york
post
all of this eventually ends up fitting
it together and apparently more
reporting is on the way
will hunter biden or joe biden be asked
any questions about that of course not
meanwhile a news story from the new york
post shows that joe biden
met with hunter's alleged business
partners in kazakhstan
so that that's exciting stuff so
apparently hunter was trading on daddy's
name and daddy full well knew about it a
new photograph has emerged of democratic
presidential nominee joe biden posing
with hunter biden and kenneth rakashev
akashic oligarch who reportedly worked
with the former veep's scandal
son the snap first published by a
kazakhstani anti-corruption website in
follows last week's bombshell post
exposes detailing hunter biden's
overseas business ceilings
and report claiming that rakash have
paid the biden scion as a go-between to
broker us investments
in the unseated photo the former vp can
be seen smiling with kazakhstan's former
prime minister
kasim massimov and his son who was
flanked by rakashev
a daily mail report published friday
detailed hunter biden's alleged work
with rakashev claiming he died regularly
with the kazakh businessman
and attempted to facilitate investment
for his cash in new york washington dc
and a nevada mining company
rakashev who enjoys close ties to
kazakhstan's kleptocratic former
president
apparently ran into trouble when western
business partners realized that the
opaque origins of his fortune
could become a political liability so
once more joe biden and hunter biden in
close cahoots
with uh with somebody who is dicey and
this is not a shock i mean going all the
way back to 2008
joe biden helps a credit card industry
win passage of a new law making it
harder for consumers to file
file for bankruptcy protection hunter
meanwhile had a 500 000
consulting agreement with one of the
largest companies pushing for the
changes
so hunter's been making bank off daddy's
name for quite a while now the
unconnected dot of course
is whether joe biden was picking up cash
for any of those there are emails that
suggest maybe
there's an email from hunter to his
daughter saying you know at least i'm
not holding
half of your money the way that pop does
to me and then there's another email
saying 20 of a chinese venture held for
hunter and ten percent held for
the big guy fox news sources say the big
guy would be joe biden
so is money flowing through to joe biden
we have literally no idea because the
media refused to ask about it because
again
when it comes to whether or not they
like the media have decided they would
rather
not report what is clearly a developing
story
and get joe biden elected then report
the developing story
if it even created the slightest doubt
about joe biden's election
this is how you end up with senator
chris murphy on national television
saying this is all probably russian
propaganda
at some point you sort of have to
believe what you see which is that
when individuals who are either
identified russian agents
or are conspiring with russian agents
are providing the information upon which
mainstream media are reporting
um you have to understand what the what
the what the deal is here and
again i'm not alone here 50 intelligent
high level intelligence
agents people who have worked in the
intelligence agencies came out and said
that this is mostly russian propaganda
okay there's no evidence it's russian
propaganda the dni has overtly said it's
not russian propaganda i'm not seeing
chris murphy being fact-checked with a
chiron
on cnn eli stokel's of msnbc suggested
that the new york post story
has been quote unquote widely disavowed
it has not been widely disavowed
there's literally not one aspect of the
new york post story that has been
debunked yet
the biden campaign refuses to say the
emails are inauthentic or even to
explain the emails this has not been
debunked there's just a lie here from
eli stokols
it's largely that no one can tell him to
stop and also that he thinks this is a
winner and he's just looking to repeat
exactly what he did in 2016 trying to
recreate the october surprise instead of
comey
and the letter he's hoping to get some
traction about the
new york post story that's been widely
disavowed um
and and is very dubious and he's trying
to do that
to defend the cult leader you must
ignore everything bad about the cult
leader or any possible bad thing about
the cult leader
if you've turned politics into a cult it
justifies nearly anything
nearly anything which is why you see the
associated press today reporting
on behalf of antifa members quote ap
finds most arrested in protests aren't
leftist radicals
well then who are they exactly so what
they say is they don't have a history of
leftist radicalism before they started
burning cop cars
i mean really this is what they say it's
hilarious they say
not to say there hasn't been violence
police cars have been set on fire
officers have been injured and blinded
windows have been smashed stores looted
businesses destroyed
of more than 300 arrested there are
about 286 defendants others had charges
dropped some live in cities like
portland and seattle where local
prosecutors declined to bring
protest related charges some of those
facing charges undoubtedly
are far left in anti-government views so
i so aren't they leftist radicals
but they say many have had no previous
run-ins with the law and no apparent
ties to antifa
well you don't have to have like
official ties with antifa to be in the
middle of an antifa
violent riot my favorite thing in this
article
is that they say these people were just
misguided they were just misguided
first of all i'd like to point something
out if you want to talk about
there's a racial narrative about
criminal justice which is that if you're
a suburban white person you get a
different standard of criminal justice
than if you're an inner city black
person
the ap here is openly stumping for it in
order to defend antifa
right they're now saying that if you go
and burn a cop car but you're a white
person from a suburban area you should
be treated differently
than if you're a black person in the
inner city and you burn a cop car that's
basically what they're saying right here
in this associated press
peace but everyone on the left will
simply ignore that because it is
inconvenient
to their narrative i love this they
actually say
in the article that people just let
their passions get the best of them
i i really this is a thing that they say
in the article
they say you know sometimes people just
like randomly
go off they randomly go off they just
they they go a little bit too far
now i know that when i go a little bit
too far that's what i do i grab a laser
pointer and then i blind a federal
officer that's
that's what i do when people go a little
bit too far
that's just that's how i roll i get a
little bit too passionate and i
immediately set a cop car on fire this
is literally what they say quote
an ap review found most of those
arrested in us protests look like
regular citizens
caught up in the moment many are young
suburban adults
oh so they're white and suburban so we
treat them differently i guess
regular citizens caught up in the moment
i i can't you know every time i get
caught up in a moment
like i'm just at a baseball game and i'm
caught up in the moment
or i'm at a religious ceremony it's like
the end of yom kippur i get caught up in
a moment
first thing i do i grab a crowbar and i
just try to beat the living hell out of
a cop i know about you that's what i do
caught up in the moment man at my
wedding i was real caught up in the
moment pretty excited about that thing
i grabbed a can of petrol and i set
somebody on fire it was good times
hey like to justify this
election outcome the media social media
they're willing to do anything anything
they're willing to defend any action
it's incredible
okay well here's the thing there could
be a backlash to this maybe it won't
come
on november 4th maybe it won't come the
day after the election maybe
maybe the backlash won't be the election
itself maybe that backlash is going to
continue to brew
and when it comes it could be a lot more
sweeping than anything that we saw
in 2016. because democrats are just
putting a lid on it
meanwhile stoking the flames underneath
meanwhile
declaring that half of americans who
disagree with them
are are deplorable evil people who uh
who support the end of all life on earth
according to elizabeth warren
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with two additional hours of content
otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wiedowsky our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
mix by mike caromina
hair and makeup is by nika geneva the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
is turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clayton
you